[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance a scenario is developing in
which Donald Trump could preemptively
pardon everybody being investigated by
Bob Muller but that string of
pre-emptive pardons could itself be the
very reason he would be impeached and
removed from office in fact it could be
the only reason he would be impeached
and removed from office a conspiracy
with Russia to manipulate the election a
combination of cash and political
influence and Trump Tower Moscow some
broader meaning to the Felix Sater email
and the statement that reportedly reads
our boy can become president of USA and
we can engineer it I will get all of
Putin's team to buy in a wholesale
campaign of obstruction of justice a
full octane White House cover-up proof
of his guilt in these cases might prove
to be utterly unnecessary in the
immediate aftermath of the pardoning of
Joe Arpaio countless lawyers and
politicians and analysts suggested this
heinous act was less about Arpaio
than it was a message to any Trump
henchman threatened by the ticking time
bomb of Muller's Trump rush a conspiracy
investigation or possibly others whose
names have yet to surface Trump's
willingness to absolve our pay owe those
observers say is a signal to the
possible Russia conspirators that he
would pardon them as well perhaps even
pardon them if they refuse to appear if
and when Muller subpoenas them to merely
testify Trump could legally he can he
would also be inheriting the wind
turning off the gravity in the American
political ecosystem and committing
presidential suicide go down this
timeline with me and consider the
reality of politics in this country for
rank-and-file Republicans in the House
in the Senate in state houses in local
politics if Donald Trump's suddenly
granted to use the language Gerald Ford
used about Richard Nixon quote a full
free and absolute pardon unto Michael
Thomas Flynn for all offenses against
the United States which he Michael
Thomas Flynn has committed or may have
committed or taken part in during the
period from August 1 2014 through August
1
17 what a Trump actually pardoned Flynn
and then what if he pardoned Flynn's
son and then what if he pardoned his own
son and then he pardoned Paul Manafort
and then pardoned Darren Kushner and
then Roger stone and then Carter Page
and Corey Lewandowski and Sean Spicer
Reince Priebus and Steve Bannon and
Sebastian Gorka and Felix aider and
Devon newness and Dana Rohrabacher and
jason Chaffetz JD gordon Michael Cohen
Julian Assange rob Goldstein Natalya
bezel Nets kiyah
Rinat Akhmetov cavil desi that's 23
possible pardons right there and that
figure assumes Trump wouldn't pardon
former ambassador Sergei kis lyac or
Vladimir Putin he could do it legally he
can do it all he would have to do is
grind the entire activity of the nation
to a complete halt government business
political media entertainment you name
it it would be Trump and his most
irrational supporters versus those of us
who have all along seen the threat he
represents plus those in the middle who
would be appalled by such a wholesale
interference in any investigation plus
most importantly of all all those
Republicans who would now have to bet
their political lives on whether or not
Trump gets away with it on whether or
not Trump gets away with it
or the Constitution prevails in other
words every Republican would have to
decide and calculate immediately
instantly whether their constituency
would be immune from the range of the
vast majority of the electorate and
setting aside the political chaos there
are the ancillary issues of the
presidential pardon to accept the pardon
and get its benefits general Flynn and
the other 22 of them would have to
tacitly admit to having committed crimes
also Trump pardons would only apply to
federal charges the Trump jr. Kushner
mana Ford vessel and its guy a meeting
was in New York if the district attorney
in New York found reason to prosecute
them and wanted to prosecute them on a
conspiracy charge the pardons would mean
nothing
except that if Trump jr. Kushner mana
Ford and bezel Mnet's kya accepted
pardons they were then walking to that
New York courtroom as defendants who had
arguably already admitted their own
guilt
anybody who accepted a trump pardon
would almost certainly also lose their
ability to use the Fifth Amendment and
to refuse to testify in federal court or
more importantly at an impeachment
hearing and trial on the grounds that
what they said might be used against
them if they would not testify that
could be jailed for contempt of Congress
but you can't pardon anybody for
something that hadn't happened yet so
Trump would then have to pardon them
again and this time he would be
pardoning people for ignoring the House
and Senate after the House and Senate
had decided these people needed to
testify and while the House and Senate
still had the absolute right to impeach
and convict him he would be forcing even
the Republicans in both chambers to make
an immediate choice while America Royals
with protests and the life of the nation
comes to a screeching halt as it did
during Watergate do they side with the
evil force who just over ruled the house
or the Senate in which they serve to
neuter their own offices and forfeit
their own power or do they use that
power to stick with the Constitution and
run Trump out of town on a rail there is
another reason besides the evidence of
the RPO pardonnez template that this
subject of pardons has come up just now
just before the storm hit last Friday
all the storms literal and political
several news outlets reported that
Muller's team had issued subpoenas to
various companies mostly lobbying firms
with which Paul Manafort had worked in
at least one case one company confirmed
that one of its key executives had been
asked to testify if there were any doubt
Muller has entered into the tell it to
the Grand Jury stage that I proposed
here on February 27th that doubt is at
an end
but there was another report in The Wall
Street Journal that told of a very
specific line of Muller inquiry that
Muller is investigating whether general
Flynn was involved in the attempt of a
now dead Republican operative named
Smith
to literally get the 33,000 deleted
Clinton emails that Trump kept praying
about during the campaign and since to
literally get those emails from people
quote around the Russian government as
we have noted previously the first time
Trump first used that number 33,000 not
30,000 not some vague estimate
specifically 33,000 Clinton emails the
first time he used that number was in a
tweet that Trump's sent no more than 20
minutes after his son and his son-in-law
and man affort met with people they
believe we're acting as middlemen
carrying damaging information about
Clinton provided by the Russian
government and now the Wall Street
Journal suggests Muller may have found
the backstory to that meeting and the
Washington Post suggests he may have
followed the money to a plan interwoven
financially and chronologically with
Trump's presidential campaign to have
Trump build a Trump Tower of Moscow with
Vladimir Putin's public endorsement of
Trump and suddenly these backstories
could elevate the June 2016 meeting from
the ranks of merely a Russian bid to see
if the Trump's were stupid enough to
take the bait to a full-fledged
international treachery and even treason
situation that so many of us have
suspected for so long if that's the case
Trump may have to come up with more than
just 23 pardons because pardons may be
his only chance of surviving a nightmare
he has created for himself in his
madness and his lust for power the
comfort is if mass pardons are his only
chance of surviving they themselves
could create such an uncontrollable
whirlwind that he would not survive it
no matter what the original truth about
Russia really is or really is not and
you and I will then live to see the day
when Trump is led out of the White House
impeached convicted removed by his own
party in disgrace to be damned through
all of history perhaps headed to prison
while he mumbles over and over again but
her emails resist
remove peace PS the book of these
commentaries and my other writings on
Trump comes out October 17th you can
pre-order it now or not or just wait for
the movie or something